♪ ♪
>> Greg: GILLETTE, OF
COMPANIES SUPPORTED BY MEN FOR
OVER A CENTURY, DEBUTED A NEW
AND CRAPPING OVER THE SAME MEN.
HARASSING WHAT -- WHAT GILLETTE
CALLS TOXIC MASCULINITY.
THE TERM OF ENDEARMENT EMBRACED
BY TEACHERS LOUNGE IS
EVERYWHERE.
TO SMEAR AN ENTIRE GENDER.
APPARENTLY GILLETTE EXECS
MUST'VE BEEN READING
"TEEN VOGUE" ."
>> BULLYING.
>> THE ME TOO MOVEMENT AGAINST
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
>> TOXIC MASCULINITY.
>> IS THIS THE BEST A MAN CAN
GET?
IS IT?
WE CAN'T HIDE FROM IT.
IT'S BEEN GOING ON FAR TOO LONG.
WE CAN'T LAUGH IT OFF.
>> WHAT I ACTUALLY THINK SHE'S
TRYING TO SAY --
>> MAKING THE SAME OLD EXCUSES.
>> BOYS WILL BE BOYS.
>> SOMETHING FINALLY CHANGED.
>> REGARDING SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
>> THERE WILL BE NO GOING BACK.
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IN THE BEST
IN MEN.
>> Greg: IT'S ALMOST AS IF THE
PEOPLE WHO MAKE PRODUCTS FOR MEN
HATE MEN.
WHAT IS GILLETTE TRYING TO SELL?
RAZORS OR ITSELF?
AS THE COMPANY LOSES MARKET
SHARE IS TO DOLLAR SHAVE CLUB,
GILLETTE MAKES AN AD THAT SHAFTS
THE COMPANY'S KEY AUDIENCE, JUST
TO SCORE A FEW VIRTUE POINTS
WITH THE SOCIAL JUSTICE MOB.
THEY SAY THEY ARE SPARKING
CONVERSATION, THAT THAT'S WHAT
THEY CALL IT WHEN THEY TIE YOU
TO A CHAIR AND SHOUT ACCUSATIONS
THAT YOU AND THEN ASKING FOR
MONEY.
HOW ENLIGHTENED IS GILLETTE?
LOOK AT THESE RACERS.
THE BLUE IS FOR MALES AND THE
PINK IS FOR FEMALES.
TALK ABOUT ENFORCING GENDER
STEREOTYPES.
THE COWARDLY MEDIA IS SCARED OF
THE SOCIAL MEDIA MOB BACKS THE
AD.
MEANWHILE EVERYBODY ELSE HATES
IT.
GILLETTE WILL SAY IT'S BECAUSE
THE AD SPOTLIGHTS BAD MALE
BEHAVIOR AND WE INSECURE RUBES,
WE CAN'T HANDLE IT.
MEL, IT'S BECAUSE THE AD SUCKS.
GILLETTE DIDN'T JUST CONDEMN BAD
BEHAVIOR, SOMETHING MOST MEN DO
WHENEVER THEY SEE IT, IT
SUGGESTED THAT BEHAVIOR
REPRESENTS THE NORM.
IT SOLD YOU OUT AND JUDGED YOU.
GILLETTE SAID OUR CONSUMERS --
YOU SHOULD APPLAUD US.
WE ARE TOO BUSY JOINING DOLLAR
SHAVE CLUB.
ALL RIGHT, DANA.
DID YOU KNOW THEY WERE SELLING
RAZORS?
WHAT WERE THEY SELLING?
>> Dana: I THINK YOU ARE RIGHT
RIGHT.
THEY REALLY WANTS US TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
I THINK YOU ARE RIGHT.
REMEMBER WHEN NIKE DID THE AD
FOR COLIN KAEPERNICK AND IT WAS
LIKE WHAT ARE THEY DOING AND
THEN THEIR MARKET SHARE WENT WAY
UP.
THEY SOLD MORE SHOES AND
PRODUCTS.
PERHAPS YOUNGER MEN ARE GOING TO
LIKE THIS AD.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> Greg: I KNOW, THEY ARE NOT.
I CAN GUARANTEE YOU KNOW MAN
LIKES THAT AD.
>> Dana: I FEEL LIKE WELL,
THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE MEN IN
THE LIVES OF BOYS.
IN AMERICA.
>> Greg: THAT WOULD BE A GOOD
AD.
>> Dana: MEN NEED TO STEP UP
TO THE CHILDREN THEY FATHER.
STICK AROUND AND BE THERE FOR
THEIR CHILDREN.
THIS TO ME IS ACTUALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT POINT.
THAT WOULD BE A BETTER AD.
>> Greg: JESSE, THEY DIDN'T
ADDRESS THAT.
THEY BASHED MEN, MEN WHO FOUGHT
WARS, BUILD BRIDGES.
THEY BASHED THEM.
>> Jesse: I DON'T WANT TO FEEL
GUILTY ABOUT THE BEHAVIOR OF A
FEW BAD APPLES.
I FEEL GUILTY ENOUGH OVER MY OWN
BEHAVIOR.
>> Greg: YOU ARE ONE BAD
APPLE.
>> Jesse: I WANT A GOOD SHAVE.
I DON'T WANT TO CONVERSATION
ABOUT ANYTHING.
THE POINT OF A RAZOR, THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT A BRAND.
I WANT TO KNOW ABOUT OUR
PRODUCTS.
YOU DON'T WEAR A RAZOR.
A RAZORS ALL ABOUT PERFORMANCE.
IT'S ABOUT HOW IT GLIDES.
YOU DON'T GET ANY NIXON CUTS.
IT'S ABOUT HOW NICE THE HANDLE
FEELS.
HOW SHARP IT IS.
I WANT TO SEE THE RAZOR GO DOWN
A MAN'S FACE AND I WANT TO SEE
THE CREAM COME OFF LIKE THAT.
THAT'S HOW I KNOW IT'S GOOD.
LIKE YOU SAID, WHAT ARE THEY
TALKING ABOUT?
WHO KNOWS.
LIKE YOU SAID, THEY ARE TRYING
TO SUCK UP TO THE MADISON AVENUE
PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY WANT TO GO
VIRAL AND THEY WANT EVERYBODY TO
TALK ABOUT HOW THEY ARE
TRENDING.
MEANWHILE, THEY ARE JUST MAKING
EVERYBODY FEEL GUILTY.
>> Greg: KATIE, I THINK VIRTUA
SIGNALING IS AN INSURANCE POLICY
AGAINST SOCIAL MEDIA MOBS.
THEY KNOW THEY'VE GOT TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND THEY KNOW THAT
EVERYBODY IN MEDIA AND
ADVERTISING IS GOING TO FALL IN
LINE BECAUSE IF THEY DON'T AGREE
WITH IT, THEN THEY COULD BE
PERSECUTED.
>> Katie: IT'S JUST STUPID.
WHO ARE YOU TRYING TO IMPRESS?
THE ENTIRE AD IS INSULTING TO
THE VERY PEOPLE WHO ARE THEIR
CUSTOMERS.
I AM GETTING REALLY SICK AND
TIRED OF MEN IN THIS COUNTRY
BEING DEMONIZED BECAUSE OF THE
BEHAVIOR OF OTHER MEN.
THERE ARE THINGS THAT WOMEN DO
THAT ARE BATTLES ALSO AND IF WE
WANT TO TALK ABOUT TOXIC
MASCULINITY, MAYBE WE SHOULD
TALK ABOUT TOXIC FEMININITY AND
TOXIC FEMINISM.
TAKING MEN OUT OF BEING
MASCULINE ISN'T GOING TO MAKE
THEIR BEHAVIOR BETTER.
IT'S ONLY GOING TO TAKE THINGS
THAT THE COUNTRY HAS BUILT
ITSELF UPON OUT OF THE PICTURE
AND MAKE THE BEHAVIOR WORSE.
MEN NEED MEN TO SHOW THEM HOW TO
BE GOOD PEOPLE, TO HAVE MORALS
AND VALUES.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THEY HAVE TO
STOP ACTING LIKE MEN.
>> Greg: THERE COULD HAVE BEEN
A POSITIVE MESSAGE, JUAN.
IN THIS CASE, IT WAS NEGATIVE.
THE ASSUMPTION MEN DON'T HAVE
SISTERS, MOTHERS, DAUGHTERS,
GRANDDAUGHTERS.
THAT WE ACTUALLY LOVE WOMEN.
IN THIS CASE, WE ARE JUST AWFUL
PEOPLE.
>> Juan: I THINK YOU ARE OFF
ON THIS.
I AM A GUY BUT WHEN I MUST SAY
WHEN IT COMES TO TALK ABOUT
RACISM AND STEVE KING, WHEN IT
COMES TO MISOGYNY AND BULLYING,
YOU GUYS REACT LIKE SOMEBODY IS
ATTACKING THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
I AM LIKE, WHAT?
>> Greg: THAT IS PURE B.S.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH RACISM
OR STEVE KING.
YOU ARE SO WRONG.
OH, MY GOD.
JUAN, THAT IS SO PATHETIC.
YOU ARE EMBARRASSING.
YOU'RE EMBARRASSING YOURSELF.
>> Juan: IN KEEPING WITH A
COMPANY HERE TO MAKE MONEY, JUST
LIKE WE TALKED ABOUT NIKE.
>> Greg: I AGREE.
JUST MAKE MONEY.
>> Juan: GIVE ME A SECOND.
YOU HAVE A COMPANY THAT I DON'T
DOUBT TESTED THIS AND FOUND THAT
MEN IN FACT ARE MOVING AWAY FROM
ALL MEN HAVE TO BE STOIC.
ALL MEN HAVE TO PROJECT --
YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE HIGH
RATES OF VIOLENCE, HIGH RATES OF
DEPRESSION, HIGH RATES OF
SPOUSAL ABUSE, MEN.
MEN UNDERSTAND THERE IS A CHANGE
TAKING PLACE AND I THINK IT'S
ALSO THE CASE THAT AS WE SEE
SHIFTS IN DEMOGRAPHICS ABOUT
HISPANIC MEN, BLACK MEN, ASIAN
MEN.
THAT THERE IS MORE AND MORE OPEN
TO THE IDEA THAT IT'S A
DIFFERENT DEFINITION OF WHAT IT
MEANS TO BE BIG DADDY IN THIS
COUNTRY.